foreign
[Music]
Starfield is our first new universe in
over 25 years but it's still a Bethesda
RPG through and through where you step
into a new world and you get that
feeling of unlimited possibilities
but this time it's not just one world
it's over a thousand worlds
because the choice of where to go it's
not ours it's yours
and it wasn't until now that we had the
technology to create it
from the rocks at your feet to the
mountains in the distance
to the people and creatures that live in
these worlds
that isn't just a backdrop that moon is
actually there orbiting the planet yes
you can visit it too
simulate the Galaxy around you
our next Generation lighting model uses
real-time Global illumination to light
the world based on the type of star and
the makeup of the planet's atmosphere
[Music]
we also have an all-new animation system
and of course you can play it in third
person
and you can play it in first person
we love exploration and rewarding it but
you do explore differently in this game
given its scale
that usually involves exploring an area
you've landed in
you can collect resources
do a mission and maybe even stumble upon
something unexpected
everything
we do love stuff and all of the items
allowing you to pick everything up and
you can view all that in your data menu
this is the hub for everything you're
doing from your skills to your ship your
missions and your inventory we love to
pack a ton of detail in every object
from all of your weapons
spacesuits
to food we just obsess over the details
and food we obsess over food
when you're done exploring you can walk
back or fast travel to your ship we have
Companions and crew you can take with
you I left vosco here back at my ship
welcome back captain
and he can even say your name
let's head out
[Music]
our mission was to convey the Wonder and
Majesty of space exploration to evoke
the Romance of the golden age of early
space flight and we've been referring to
this approach as NASA Punk this means a
design language where the tech is
advanced yet still looks grounded and
relatable for us it's a contrast that's
where the visual interest is obviously
the NASA which is the rigid pod function
over style and then Punk which is all
about Style
you can see that visual style coming
through in your ship your ship is your
home for you and your crew and like many
of the spaces in our game it has a
slightly retro and analog touch a bit of
low-fi rather than sci-fi where
everything is well used worn and lived
in alrighty what's the plan captain
this is your star map it starts with the
planet you're currently on
you can see all of its info and
resources you can choose a landing spot
or fast travel to known locations
backing out further you can view all the
planets in the system obviously the game
is big and it's here you can see planets
that have key locations missions or life
on them versus the many planets that are
Barren but resource heavy
zoom out even further to see all the
systems in this part of the Galaxy
here you can plot a course to ones that
are light years away this uses your
ship's grav drive to fold space and jump
to these systems and you will need to
upgrade your shipping skills if you want
to jump to the most distant ones but for
now we'll plot a course to the Alpha
Centauri system where we can find the
city of New Atlantis
foreign
course while we scan your ship's cargo
[Music]
scan complete
are cleared for landing at new Atlantis
[Music]
as soon as you land in a city like new
Atlantis your eyes are guided upwards to
just these boundless vast buildings
it's the biggest city we've ever made
not just in size but also in the amount
of custom art
crowds and quests
so the main focus when we're designing a
city is obviously what supports the
story we try and tell as many small
stories as possible this is a colony war
memorial it's a few moments of gameplay
that make the space feel like it's full
of real characters that are going about
their day-to-day lives it's paralyzed if
you really stop and think about it buddy
it's coffee it's also where your
adventure with constellation begins
[Music]
foreign
we have a lot to talk about by the time
you meet them constellation is sort of
seen as this mythical group most people
don't even know they exist anymore
they're the last true explorers in the
galaxy and they're trying to find the
answers to some of Humanity's biggest
questions the artifacts are so different
so alien and I'm certain one of them
reached out and spoke to you
[Music]
the artifact if you could place it on
the table here
oh my God
but how it's coming together the
set the Buy and Tell
side the settled systems it's definitely
an Eclectic cast of characters you've
got Sarah Morgan the ex-soldier and
adventurer now constellations leader
Mateo the Theologian who believes that
there's definitely something else out
there Noel the gifted scientist and
Sarah Morgan's Protege and Walter a very
successful businessman in the settled
systems and constellations financier
anything goes as long as you have the
money there's also Vlad the ex-pirate
Sam Coe the former Space Cowboy and
baron you know what I hate about these
Pirates
completely resistant to my otherwise
irresistible charm
the journey you take with constellation
is just the first that many you'll
embark on the settled systems is home to
all kinds of different stories people
and Adventures for you to uncover
[Music]
the United Colonies is where you'll find
new Atlantis the first major human
settlement in space
people who live here value law
discipline and the legacy of humanity
they consider themselves the true
children of Earth you ever think of
joining up with a Vanguard help the
United Colonies even get your UC
citizenship new Atlantis isn't the only
city within the United Colonies
the city of Sedonia on Mars to this day
serves as the largest Mining facility
for the United Colonies
beyond the United Colonies reach you
might find yourself in a much more wild
and independent Coalition of star
systems
[Music]
this is Freestar Collective space
capital of the Freestar Collective is
Aquila City
Stone route inn is an Aquila City
fixture
Ranger relies on judgment and intuition
to do what's best for the people
neon started out as a fishing platform
but is now known throughout the cell
systems as a pleasure City where almost
anything goes if you've got morality
issues this definitely isn't the job for
you
[Music]
ryugen is hiring the best and brightest
of today for our future tomorrow
everyone has been chewed up and ground
up by Neon try not to get yourself
killed alright
outside the bounds of civilized space
there are still plenty of unclaimed
systems to explore but these areas are
also home to the most hostile factions
in the galaxy
the Great Serpent hungers all heathens
shall be made Dust In Time
a new face this is the face of a brave
Runner here to challenge the Red Mile
they think the Galaxy is theirs they are
wrong it belongs to the Crimson Fleet it
always has
in Starfield we're pushing our cities
and settlements further than we ever
have before it's all there waiting for
you a slice of Humanity's future
so ready to get out there